hey David how can I stop drowning in
email my email inbox is out of control
it feels like I spent all day on email
and don't actually get my job done
WTF okay so listen there there are
endless strategies to deal with this a
common I'm not gonna go through all the
ones that we hear but a common one that
you hear is check email only at preset
times check email at 9:00 a.m. and then
4:00 p.m. and then that's it and then
very often when people get that advice
they will say but in my job I'm not able
to do that now a lot of times the people
who say in my job I'm not able to do
that they actually would be able to do
it if they really thought through a way
to generate expectations that you're not
going to be on email all day but this is
a real problem there are lots of jobs
where 50 60 70 % of the day is going to
just keeping up with email rather than
actually doing the value generation of
the job so let me concede to you you are
in one of those jobs where you can't
just check email a few a couple times a
day or something like that I have
successfully cut down my email time I
would estimate by 75 or 80 percent with
a very simple three-step strategy okay
the strategy is Auto filtering manual
triaging and then batch processing okay
it sounds complicated it's not
complicated at all
alright first you start with Auto
filtering any I'll talk about for me you
apply this to yourself I'm on a bunch of
different newsletters that contain
articles I might want to read or stories
that might be good for the show I've got
wrap-up services of what happened on you
know what happened on Fox News all these
different things so I can pick things
that I want to use for the show anything
related to we get all sorts of emails I
mean thousands and thousands of emails
every month about people's membership
payments that came in people's
membership payments that failed new
subscriptions cancellations all that
stuff everything I just listed gets Auto
filtered into folders all of my
newsletter services are automatically
filtered into and out of my inbox and
into a folder everything that's
membership related gets filtered into a
separate folder I never see that stuff
in my inbox that is nine
percent of my email right there great
I'm nine-tenths of the way there then
you've got to manually triage okay I go
through email more often than some
people and maybe I don't need to but we
do have things that come up with the
production of the show tech issues might
have to be in touch with affiliates or
sales issues or anything get involved in
like a you know figuring out whether an
advertiser is a good fit for us or not
or something like that so I need to see
if those urgent things come in but those
take under 30 seconds to respond to okay
and what my goal is is I never want to
look at an email more than two times I
look at it the first time can I answer
this email in under 30 seconds if it
even needs a response if the answer is
yes I do it some people say you do your
10 second responses everything else gets
triaged if the email takes more than 30
seconds for me to answer I ask myself
does that this have to be done today or
does this have to be done this week if
it's longer than this week I file it and
put a note in my calendar to revisit it
when it needs to be revisited if it's an
email that needs to be dealt with today
I move it to a folder called today if
it's something that needs to be done
this week I move it to a folder called
this week and then at the end of the day
I'll go to my today folder and one after
the other deal with every email that had
to be answered today I am condensing the
email answering periods of the day
drastically anything that's under 30
seconds that really is of a more urgent
nature even though we could debate
whether it's really that urgent or not
gets answered right away and then I look
at my auto filtered stuff membership
emails those newsletters articles stuff
like that once a day or every other day
or whatever this has cut down 75% on the
time I spend on email that's my
suggestion there are services that can
also help with the stuff there are some
services that will gather similar types
of emails and keep them out of your
inbox until you want them delivered you
might say deliver these at 4:30 p.m. and
then you get them all at once
for example I've not found the need to
use those services but I know people who
have found them useful that is my
approach critique it use whatever of it
might be useful for you reduce the
amount of time you're spending on email
because at listen I want to be spending
time researching stuff for the show
generating value creating
content and when I cut down my email 75%
I'm drastically increasing the amount of
time I can spend on just making the best
possible show we've got a great bonus
show coming up for you today make sure
to sign up at david pakman.com slash
membership or at patreon.com slash david
pakman show i'll speak to you then